you are professional for many years now
a successful professional what qualities
are need you do according to you to be a
good fantasy writer what question all
qualities are needed to be good fantasy
where there well I think it helps but
the main part is to be good right
is this a thing to write a comic book
fantasy different form but you know
ultimately it all comes down to story
there are people in in my field and of
course I've been mostly working in
science fiction and fantasy since I
first began to publish and horror even
extension there are people that are
writers who will tell you that these are
three completely different fields that
science fiction is here and fantasy is
over the earth and therefore polar
opposites and never the twain shall meet
and I don't know where they were horror
somewhat down here science but I've
never I've never recognized that
difference you know when I was a kid
reading reading voraciously
I read Robert a Heinlein I read an HP
Lovecraft a river beneath Howard and
then later kr Tolkien and some of these
would be classified fantasy of some
bizarre and some science fiction to me
they were all stories that were met
they're stories no stories that took me
of the worlds and other times and other
other planets or dimensions or what have
you and my attorney hell out of them I
didn't see these as totally different
things and I still don't
I think these distinctions are largely
false ones the arrogance of money
furnishings and I've moved from one to
another freely throughout my career I
may be one of the writers of the last
generation to be able to do that at
least in the United States I have to
keep remembering but I'm not here in the
United States of in Switzerland in the
rules may be very different here but
American publishing have become very
rigid in recent decades
I know foreigners younger writers that
myself we are writing science fiction
and a read of fantasy and apologists as
well you cannot write both of these you
must have two different names you can
write science fiction there says Phil
Jones but the new must be Fred Smith on
your reigning fantasy because otherwise
you will infuse the readers I am
actually everything that readers are
smarter than that same writer writes
different you know different things
under under the same name you know
certainly the readers of cash generators
had no difficulty doing that Robert a
Heinlein wrote fantasy HP Lovecraft or
science fiction week and these are all
just made-up stories so the main thing
to be a good writer I think this is you
know you you have to have talent you
have to have skill with words that seems
really obvious but not everyone has it
good ears or crows in particular if
you're going to write something like
comic books or television and film
there's so much for it rests on dialogue
do you have to have a good ear for
dialogue and the way people actually
speak and the individuality to give each
character his own method of speaking and
outside sometimes teach writing classes
and their various exercises you can give
the students and one of them is to
describe a half-dozen different
characters and then write a speech for
each of these characters without an
intake just say okay here's a priest and
here's a soldier and here's a housewife
and here's a prostitute and here's a you
know invent whatever you want write a
speech for each of them in which they
don't refer to their expression they
don't give their name but just make each
speech sound different from the other so
you can instantly know just from the
words this is a priest speaking this is
the prostitute speaking and that kind of
the talent to do that if they all sound
the same you know the problem they
should sound different another thing is
did empathy and interest in human beings
I mean character is the heart of all
stories I don't care to rate of science
fiction fantasy horror or mainstream
story literary fiction mystery novel
historical fiction it's all about the
people who inhabit it is all about the
characters and there will be many
different kinds of characters and you
should be able to have a certain amount
of empathy for them and that's certainly
one thing that I've tried very hard to
make part of my my fiction even even if
you're writing from the viewpoint of
someone who has not at all Nero it was a
villain perhaps would
civility he has his motivations he has
his reasons
he doesn't know started think he's the
villain nobody gets up in the morning as
soon as I read it what the old famous
can I think today except possibly the
Red Skull or in Marvel Comics but even
the better normal village don't do that
dr. doom had his own reasons for doing
what he did dr. Doo thought he was well
justified thank you